ce l'avete presente tipo human full flat
del gioco dove ti puoi arrampicare sulle
cose puoi buttare gli altri giu ecco
diciamo che io e pietro abbiamo fatto un
altro episodio di sta roba perché erano
un po che non lo facevamo ne è valsa la
pena ve lo assicuro buona visione
ci sono ciao amici visto abbracciando e
non sapevano è diverso c'è l'amico nonno
via che mi toccare il cavani mi stai
tenendo dalla parte sbagliata della
persona aia dai sono anche dalla
strategica di in testa alle migliaia o
che bocca il tuo ne ha partecipato il
lago ancora e con esse una persona si
stanno commettendo persona vede che
siete tutti quanti la famiglia
kartoffeln miral you from here and
italian you know spaghetti pizza
berlusca perché berlusca allora andiamo
adesso salvini quasi mi sun nissa che
riconosce in germania a cannavaro sono
arrivato alle scale ci ho messo una vita
e schiere le scale clienti questo tipo
prego ora chiudiamo lasciamo la perna
lascia la perdita o la no no no lascia
aperta la porta
lascia la porta aperta lasciarlo aperto
no che sì la morale si è arrivati al
punto successivo ho mancato ciò che sale
questi starò questo il fico guardo
materassi è caduto guarda che ha preso
una testata la testa tagliata come di
sterline qua io penso di sfondare il
vetro viene né scemi come di trovarmi mi
chiamo lati staresti stacco fissata per
bar e ballate vive mano coloriti no no
no no mi ammazzo vi denuncio tutta vi
faccio disinstallare il gioco pistola il
virus nel computer fate cagare
nuovo prestigioso piacere che rimane il
trenino su questo materasso di un fatto
non fatemi uscire e fa bene se connesso
un'altra persona quanto prima questo
tizio o cosa fa sono andrea e andrea
diprè ma come la strada fatta
regolamenti ricordi il pensare il muro
spalle al muro
mettiti in mezzo dove per favore fai
entrare
ok viper scandalo non penso che vada
bene se vai vai vai boom da quanto è
difficile passare in questo posto
proprio di testa la palla ma va mica di
andrea chiesi poi come trovo anche noi
non ci prova sono sicuramente questo è e
sarà appesa lui è arrivato è stato molto
difficile ma la palla demo iniziale ci
si può attendere
non lo so però qui cioè non devo io sono
arrivata nella parte opposta
qui fatto poco mandarla si sa ancora
cosa serve ma sfondato un muro ma sei
scemo e mio muro quello a per la porta a
vetri apre la porta a 3
apri ma dopo quale pulsante collegano di
la cia ok siamo entrati noi andiamo
avanti importante questi non aveva
tirare ed è come ci arriva su
ma dai davvero questo ma questo serve
per bloccare la porta
qualcuno avrà un po quito ma se sta leva
andrea bye bye ma allora è meglio che
hai scritto niente più faccio lira blog
con corrobora non aspetta devo devo
bloccarla con questi aspetta che ce l'ho
già
la mia fidatevi sono l'ingegnere color
menta o che botta possiamo citare con la
scatola ora mi sono arrivato qua sta
porta per quello che mi schiaccia puzza
bravissimo a schiacciarlo allora
se provando a cork facendo altra roba
qua dobbiamo fare una gara una gara
acqua in cima ma devi aprire una porta
qua non so come hanno già fatto quello
scemo parte faccio un blocco che doveva
quanto forte questo perché mai dai cobas
è crollato il giorno mi sa che non
dovevamo fare questa parte male e ora è
no e non lo so chiedere il mana che ha
aperto la porta va là
e ora che si fa sono stato un po che non
ho idea di come la faccia di salvataggio
tipo arrivato il primo arrivato ai a
cavallo apriti sesamo grazie aspetta
bloccarla con quanta marigliano da
sempre dammi la mano
entra dentro le intenderemo perché sono
rilasciati sara ciao fermo fermo qui si
entra lenti se volevano fuori tema april
la app rileva che gli spetta cittadini
qua e in 30
potete vedere aia non possono scendere e
salire invece tutto questo non posso
togliere braccio che male
aprite non posso togliere bravi giorno
dopo si apre non si apra porta aprite la
porta o il braccio incastrato aprite la
porta davvero massimo per la portone
valera e io rimango il cavo per sul
braccio di non sbagliarmi il braccio da
una sega carica per tutti è vero ma
vietato mi ha fatto di partire dal
problema pezzi ovviamente questo qua su
due a mettere dentro mal di chi era in
ogni arma di chi a quello scemo sto
sopra le cose
no no no vai vai ma non basta cosa fa
ora che non ci arriva scommette di
pochissimo già arrivato e cozza gente
non sa salire non sa salire niente è
veramente uniti a cuba questi due sono
un po particolare dall altra l'altro è
bravissimo questo qua è che non è un po
scemo
avevo pensato fare quando tirare questo
lo so se tu sopravvive si ok agli occhi
ma ora va bene alla leva cielo arriva
ora qua chi l'ha tirata valorizzazione
che nel ati radeon rotto noi
coordinatori va bene bravo mamma mia
come forte abbiamo o no dai
ma no dai un maggiolino così quindi
abbia finito livello si è finto
diverranno toglietevi capitò di stage in
testa vai
hai visto che forza aprendo in 22 22 la
donna che testata gli ho dato a julian
ariete fetta premi fatta per pretendere
che il mazzo per martino privati che vai
vai vai più destra 6 pollici
aprite la porta rita papa non così certi
grazie gentile
ecco che spesso si passava la mia testa
ok la bethesda ma lei vuole lì come fa a
essere lì ma la minerve boschi portici
sempre lui c'è come può essere già
qualche fortissimo terrare prima qua e
ti chiedi se esiste perché qua c con il
tempo che fa e poi deve trasportare
aspetto spiega la funziona scherzavano
un po come mi lasci stare certi funeral
bara poi ora poi un dolore dalla gabbia
ti potevi sorgere la gabbia ci sono due
modi per farlo non lo sapevo tindari
carrista parte ravelli p è partito
qualcuno si no una roccia
hai mai avvisare la roccia deve sfondare
il muro capito io io ok
let's do this video girati negli atti
allegati al quale nero cercato sei
arrivato lì dopo a quella mi vuole
buttare giù una famiglia fa mise alla
leva ma dove sono finite ebbene oggi
decide lui come gioco oggi anno siamo
riusciti anche a suicidarsi dei falliti
nel suicidio
guarda io cosa faccio qui ok c'è quanto
preso da un te lo meriti pirla ma di chi
vuoi mollare ma ricolazione aprile ci
prova di idiota non farò mai sbagliare
ecco appunto saltati prendo il mio amico
vieni beta che cosa lui ok siamo
presentati perfetto cui lasciamo tanto
ha segnato la lasci di ricavo di una
casetta messo non c'è niente dentro
faccio un camino rho permesso entrò nel
cammino nuovo operai con ice
ciao amici ma dai voto 1 giu mi buttano
è stato bellissimo
orca vecchio ora che fenomeno ninja
prova a fare la giusta roba ma ma ma
questi giocano contro di noi
io non sono così finito livello
aspettami marshmallow
guardali che fenomeno che sono quanto
bravo quindi regazzoli questa io non so
il flash
tutto qua perché poi sono andati avanti
realtà due ore perché questo gioco qua
perdere la cognizione del tempo e ti
ritrovi che ci hai giocato tutto il
pomeriggio e sei andato in after non te
ne sei accorto però che veramente figo
solo chi è che sembra fatto apposta per
youtube sto gioco perché succedono una
cagata dopo l'altra però è veramente
figo quei ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto come se ci sono mi piace il
viaggio il canale anche di quell'infame
di pietra in descrizione siamo stati
discreti noi ci vediamo a un passo da
ragazza
[Musica]